dan please sack MLB Network analyst back
here on the show how are you Dan
doing good rich yeah this should be a
you know what it's gonna kind of be a
contrast of series with it Yankees in
the Astros the last one that bullpen
game six this is a more traditional way
isn't it three to two teams what each
with three really good starters and it
doesn't get any better than coal in
Scherzer in Game one Gerrit Cole big
statement I think he's going to be the
first forty million dollar pitcher when
he hits the free agent market rich I've
been following big league baseball since
1986 and at this fans Roger Clemens
Randy Johnson Dolan Ryan I don't think
I've ever seen a pitcher with the
Arsenal that Gerrit Cole has right now
he said good he is that good are you
surprised though he's a game one starter
not a game three starter cuz that would
mean he could go in Game seven are you
surprised about that decision from AJ
Hinch Dan Cusack no I don't think so you
know I think it's more keeping these
guys on their normal rest and their
normal routine and I feel like this I
know that like Vegas thinks that the
Nationals don't have much of a shot I
think they do but I think it's going to
be imperative for the Nationals to get
out of here one of these two games they
can't go back down o to the Nationals
ballpark because this absolu good but
this is a really good national scene and
we talked a couple of weeks ago the one
team that scared everybody including the
Dodgers would be that that's if they got
in they got in in Stephen Strasburg in
Scherzer right now throwing as good as
Verlander and Cole this could be a
dynamite wolf theory I mean that's the
matchup for Game two to right I mean
it's Verlander versus Strasburg and then
Scherzer versus Cole but it just seems
to me that I don't know Danna I you know
I've been following the game for a long
time too I didn't play it like you it
just seems to me back in the day game 3
was the start you got to put your best
starter in Game three certainly to put
him on the road in Game three so you got
a game seven now it just seems like this
is the version of analytics like we just
take it game the game ending the inning
picture to picture you know match up to
match up doesn't matter how many there's
how many times that you've been through
the the
the order back in the day now that's
what matters is that's what happening
here they got to get to Game one and
then just deal with Game two when you
get to it
dan I think what it is for rich I think
in this fight is I think AJ Hinch he
realizes that he has a guy that's really
hot right now and Gary Cole and he'd
like to keep him on that five-day
rotation you know we've made a lot of
guys coming back on short rest and
pitchers and baseball players in general
our creatures of habit they like to stay
on a five-day routine I think the way I
think the game is looked at differently
than it was even say five years ago or
ten years ago when you look at the 10
game series the seven game series as a
whole and you kind of kind of
strategically plan like what would be
the best way to maximize our starters
but I think what we're seeing now
baseball in 2019 is when tonight's game
already about tomorrow's game tomorrow
and if all else fails what we Hannibal
will turn it over we'll do a bull
fighting type of games like what
happened game six between the Astros and
Yankees I wasn't surprised I think right
now if if you are the Astros and if I
were AJ Hinch there's no doubt I would
run Derek Cola he's the closest thing in
the sport right now to a sure thing now
that would that said he's due for a
clunker he's been unbelievably good for
almost three months but I think if I
were AJ Hinch I probably would do this
when you have two guys like Cole and
Verlander the guy that surprised me rich
nekron hasn't been as good in an Astra
uniform as I thought he was going to be
I thought at the trade deadline when
they acquired that Greinke I thought it
was over just mail it in the Astros
we're gonna get to the World Series and
they were gonna win it easily
Jack Greinke hasn't been to Zack Greinke
that were used to so Game three it's
exactly I think if you look at it like I
would almost favor Patrick Korbin over
Zach Greinke negates right and that's
going to be in Nationals Park next week
coming up right here on the rich Iser
later on this week dan please sack of
the MLB Network right here on the show
in the Honda inside a report so we've
been so deep into how the Yankees
matchup with Houston and vice versa
because we saw that ALCS on the horizon
for weeks and months how about the Nats
they match up with Houston in your
estimation Dan rich they they're a hot
team right now how we can pick is
swinging it back really well the
nation's gonna get a chance to see what
a great player Anthony Rendon is he's a
call so a free agent he's a terrific
player and one so to the left fielder
for the Nationals three dynamic players
right now Zimmerman has really swung the
bat well this is a Nationals team right
now that everybody feared if they got in
they they got hot because of their
started pitching but I think what it
surprised everybody is myself included
they could hit they could hit and they
could score some runs I'm looking at
this series you know you're always
looking for those two x-factor guys I
just think the starting pitching is so
good in both of these but both of these
teams when you go to the bullpens and I
think one guy from each team is going to
determine who wins this series will
Harris might be the most
underappreciated reliever on the Houston
Astros team everybody wants to talk
about Ozuna in the back end of the
bullpen and I think to me will Harris is
the one guy that they can bring in in
the seventh and or eight with guys on
base you can bring him in in traffic he
spits great baseball for the Astros for
three or four years I think he's gonna
have to come up really big and on the
flip side for the Nationals Sean
Doolittle stole the ball much better
since he came off the injured list with
that bum knee if will Harris and Sean
Doolittle to me they're gonna be the
keys to both of these bullpens and I
think which either one of these two guys
yes I think one of these two teams are
better chance to win and then it's the
first postseason ever to feature five of
the top ten pitchers and strikeouts I
mean my gosh is we all know it's a walk
strikeout homerun League whose which
teams better at putting the bat on the
ball do you think just contact I think
the Astros are a little bit better
putting the ball in play
I don't think sometimes we gave that
Yankees pitching staff enough credit
that Yankee staff threw the ball really
well in that series I look at this
Astros team you could talk about Michael
Brantley puts the ball in play Bregman
puts the ball in play George Springer at
times gets a little bit free swinger but
he could put the ball in play this is an
Astros lineup that didn't hit they hit
under 200 against the Yankees but I
think if you're gonna talk which team is
better offensively
I think the net the Astros are better
offensive ly and they put the ball and
play
I think you'll see fewer strikeouts from
the Astros that you will for the
National dam police a couple more
minutes left with MLB Network Stan
please sack here on the Rich Eisen show
guys don't maybe the guys on both
rosters they don't play or pitch another
game in in the major leagues their Hall
of Famers what do you got for this world
slander he's pretty much a since he's in
my Max Scherzer is more than likely and
those two would be the only two that I
would say right now that would be slam
dunks to begin not outright on his way
to the Hall of Fame highway I mean he's
got he obviously he's at the beginning
of his career what about outside I look
at these two teams they're the best two
teams right now they're the best two
teams and you know some people think
Steven I think the coolest things so far
the Stephen Strasburg has kind of
changed that narrative everybody wants
to go back to that series against the
st. Louis Cardinals a few years ago
where he wasn't a part of he's really
been a terrific postseason pitcher and
he has a chance in this world series to
make everybody forget about not pitching
in the postseason a few years ago right
rich he's been throwing the ball great
he's one of the top 10 pitchers in the
sport and I know he can flip the nerd if
this guy throwing the ball great right
now
what about Altuve I think he's a Hall of
Famer if and he doesn't swing the bat
anymore but as a Yankee fan I wish he
didn't what do you think I do too I you
know what please another thing that is
so beautiful about the game of baseball
you don't have to be 6-3 215 pounds he's
five six maybe you saw the homerun off
of her oldest cabin it's just amazing
how such a small guy can have such a big
impact on a game he's the one guy and I
know a lot of people talk about Bregman
to third baseman but if I were to posing
pitcher and had nowhere to go and one
guy I would least want to face I would
not want any part of l2v
he's the best bad ball hitter in the
game he hits good velocity it's good
breaks balls he has the flair for
dramatics I think you're on to something
if he can keep this up for a few more
years he might be right on the
hall-of-fame Highway unless the last one
for you a moment for for me your Brian
Cashman what do you
pay coal all that money what's the
maneuver to try and get past this
Houston team and stay in front of a Red
Sox team or a surging race team what do
you do if your Cashman is off the guy I
think that the games matched up there
they were really even Steven with the
Astros but when it came down to it I
thought that the reason that the Astros
won that series they were able to win
two out of three games
Yankee Stadium and the game that Gerrit
Cole said he didn't have his best stuff
but he got it through seven innings and
I think that's the one thing that the
Yankees are missing right now to knock a
big-game pitcher
Severino you would expect if he's
healthy next year he's at least a number
two but if they could get Gerrit Cole
one that would wink at the Astros and
make the Yankees that much better I
think that's what they're missing rich
they're missing that really that go-to
guy as there aren't very many of them
but Gerrit Cole is one of those guys Dan
thanks for the time enjoy the series
it's gonna be great I can't wait to sit
back and watch some of it too and and
we'll get you on another time as much as
you'd like
you got you got you got you back you
right back at you again Dan it's part of
MLB network's World Series coverage live
from Minute Maid Park in Nationals Park
before and after every World Series game
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on VR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app